claude moine alias schmoll alias eddy
mitchell est au casino de paris
il est remis de son angine qui lui avait
cassé la voix lors du premier concert et
ils renouent donc sur la scène avec la
scène après six ans d'absence d'un
gregotti avance à weyer on mettait les
voitures dans les rues avec deux haut
parleurs n'ont pas passé la télé tu
n'aimais pas ça non pourquoi mais parce
qu avant impression de charmed a retapé
du service après vente
[Musique]
côté coulisses ou côté scène il ne mâche
pas ses mots notre crooner comédiens
présentateurs de charme
pas de quartier pour la télévision le
cinéma exception faite de sa vocation
comme il dit ce qu'il préfère chanter
un choix que je m'amuse à présenter une
émission de cinéma soit un petit écran
qu'il en tous les cas le palace de
beaumont-sur-oise célèbre grâce à la
dernière séance entame glorieusement une
deuxième carrière
réaction à chaud on a fait des salles
aussi ridicules où il y en a besoin
d'une très belle salle quand même en
salle de spectacle on en a fait des
trois petites salles en ridicule les
gens sont venus chez eux devant leur
télé donc il faut savoir ce qu'il veut
le faire un six majeur est aussi le côté
l'exploitant quand il vient pleurer faut
savoir aussi que les ses ou aussi que
faire de l'argent et quand il a passé
une belle salle pour en faire trois
minable faut pas qu'ils pleurent
aujourd'hui vous parler de la télé vous
l'aimez bien vous la terrible du tout on
ne fouille pas vraiment même bien pour
les infos pour la météo pour choses
comme ça mais sinon je reprends mon
plein vous en fait quand même oui mais
moi je fais j'ai pas l'impression de
faire de la télé justement parce que je
représente du film c'est différent non
mais je parle de la télé en général dont
129 et vous pensez par exemple à vous
sacrifier à quoi la mention promotion
pour annoncer que on est con et complète
on fera donc enfin un spectacle
supplémentaire au zénith le 12 décembre
sinon quel intérêt
[Musique]